تحضيرات لا تعرف الليله من النهار في
روسيا استعدادا لاحياء يوم النصر الثلاثاء
المقبل
ساحات نابضه تضوج بفعاليات ذكرى الانتصار
على النازيه قبل 78 عاما
مشهد هذا العام سيكون مختلفا ليس فقط بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا بل بسبب مخاوف امنيه
خصوصا بعد استهداف الكريم
موسكو ليست وحدها التي تحيي يوم النصر بل
كل الاقاليم التابعه لها
لكن هذا العام مختلف حيث تم الغاء
الاحتفالات في سته اقاليم لاسباب امنيه
وفق مسؤولين
اخر الالغاءات كان احتفال مقاطعه بريانسك
التي تبعد
451 كيلو مترا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
الغاء من نوع اخر اشارت اليه صحيفه
الجاردن البريطانيه اذ الغى الرئيس بوتين
ولاول مره مسيره الفوج الخالد التي ترفع
فيها صور قتلى روسيا في مواجهه النازيه
المسيره العسكريه ستكون خاليه من الجنود
المتعاقدين وستقتصر على مجندين بسبب الحرب
اما في بعض الاقاليم سيكون على المنظمين
الابداع لاطفاء مظهر طبيعي وفق الصحيفه
ما تمر به روسيا منذ اكثر من عام غير
الكثير من المسلمات حتى احتفالات يوم
النصر رغم كل ما تحمل من رمزيه في وجدان
كل روسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات